now what is the impact of this pandemic
in the I'm gonna call it near-term which
is twelve months or less and then far
term and I'll call it the future so near
term hundred twelve months we're sitting
here twenty summer of twenty twenty-one
and then in the future past twenty you
know twenty two and forward well um
let's see so yeah I've done so much
riding on this trying to whittle my
thoughts down right yeah me too even you
know I think the near-term we're aware
of right travels decimated people
whether they should or should not are
living in a lot of fear right and it's
surprising for me the spectrum of fear
that people do or don't live in people
are pent up you know yes there's
explosive moments happening that are
also there because of you know obviously
because the police violence you know
plus people being communauté pent up for
long it's like they just people just
need to get out you know and so plus
three years of Trump plus yes
uncertainty on an economic future yes
anytime you have over twenty percent
unemployment of it specifically young
men 18 to 30 years old we saw it in
Greece Spain the Middle East yes that
leads to violence and so the the violent
contingent of and it's not part of the
protest but I think there's a violent
contingent of eluding whatever is
certainly socio-economic related right
yeah well I mean I so if we think about
a little bit midterm I think what you'll
see is there's going to be a mass you
know increase in mental health problems
there's a mass increase in drug usage I
think that's gonna come out really bad
my bigger fear is I think there's just
going to be a bigger split between
socio-economic levels like I think that
you know for for wealthy individuals or
people that still are maintaining jobs
they're at home they're doing their work
they feel you know very you know less
impacted I think what we'll find is that
a lot of the retail jobs and the
restaurant jobs you know just frankly a
bunch of them won't come back because I
don't know about you but you know I
would probably guess that one in five
local retailers and restaurants I
interact with are just not planning on
reopening because this basically put
them out of business and so one in five
would be
I think a low estimate I might put it at
one in four
I wouldn't go to one in three but I
think one in four is where I would have
put it at objects I think naturally
that's terrifying when you think about
it all those empty storefronts but that
also creates an opportunity so then a
long term all those empty storefronts
all this extra capacity of humans
sitting at home saying I need a job and
there's not one for me I need to make
one yep or some you know if one in a
hundred people who don't have a job say
I'm gonna make a job for myself that
could be a company so I agree and so
that's interesting right and so it
provides that opportunity I think that
we've we proven that remote work works
which i think is a big deal it's a big
deal right because I don't know about
you but now when we're looking at both
investments and when I look at my
investments looking at staff they're no
longer looking at just Los Angeles right
and they're very open to remote work
which means that I think we can find a
lifting of employment in areas that
haven't been so benefited from you know
early-stage technology which is
wonderful so I think you could see a
lift in cities that aren't so over you
know over funded and we could see some
of this venture capital and this
early-stage dollars actually going into
other cities that maybe aren't LA San
Francisco New York so that could lift
those local economies which is exciting
the other thing I think could happen is
people that felt like they were
sacrificing their life by having to live
in these major cities and live in
conditions that maybe weren't great they
might choose not to live in those cities
they might choose to move out to the
country and move out to more rural areas
where their dollar goes a lot further
and they can have our better quality of
life so you know I I kind of always
suspected that kind of remote work might
work but I don't know about you Jason
but you know ever since I was you know
basically 20 21 I'd been going to an
office basically every day in my life
right yeah it's a pretty fun habit to
stop agree and it's hard to conceive of
what we do working never meeting people
in person and in fact your thesis was
I'm long LA um science is my opportunity
you pitched lp's I'm certain on LA is
the next Silicon Valley correct I would
never have said that Silicon Valley is
the next Silicon
okay number one in it along with mark
Susur right you tune right our tip of
the spear there so that and then I moved
up to the valley from LA specifically
because I was like I the deal flow so
ridiculous mm-hmm and nobody wants to
compete against Y Combinator and I'm
uniquely qualified to do that I'm going
all-in yeah and so is a very interesting
position to be in to now having founders
want to come to an accelerator or
investors wanting to invest in a company
without ever meeting them in person yeah
so when you made investments without
being people in person and we've done
you know we've we've we've on-boarded
around six companies into our studio
with their perspective of them going
into our venture fund during this
pandemic you know two of them I haven't
met in person I have regular zoom calls
with them so I feel connected to them I
feel connected to the pace my team is
fully engaging with them but to your
point it's not important that they're in
LA at this point like you know you're
exactly it was a hard habit to break
it took this moment to show the world or
at least show me that my work and
granted this is very information centric
work right if I was a warehouse worker
if I was a retail operator right now I
might be offended because I'm like look
I can't work from home what do you talk
about my jobs physical I have to go do
things in person but for my category of
work and many of the startups who work
it we can work from home which in
essence means we can kind of work
anywhere which opens up a different
perspective I think on life and
different perspective on family and I
think that um you know it'll actually
probably lift the country in a better
way than previously having everything so
geocentric it's really fascinating that
it takes a crisis like this for
everybody to adopt it see I don't think
remote work would work unless a hundred
percent of people were forced to do it
for some period of time
totally agree because you would have so
much resistance in so many places where
you know if you're a Matt Mullenweg and
you're like WordPress is virtual and
then this other person is virtual and
Chris Sacca is like I'm virtual outcome
parachuting into Silicon Valley for two
days make investments and then go back
to Truckee wherever he was living like
those were like cute quaint like less
than 10% of the market yeah so you
couldn't actually make remote work work
but
now if Facebook and Twitter are saying
we're remote first or we're hybrid
yep wow that's a game-changer I totally
rain change it's a game-changer and I
think that'll open up changes for
education which are really fascinating I
do think one you know highly negative
consequences I just can't see a world
where we don't see increased taxes right
the the you know the the pig going
through the Python right now of the debt
that weren't you know that that we're
accumulating as a country the company's
being shut down the hostels being shut
down the universities having challenges
I think at the end of the day that's
gonna come back you know to bite us
pretty strong and Trump and the future
President may or may not try to delay
that but at some point we're gonna pay
the price you know of this timeframe and
it's probably gonna result in taxes and
then almost every other time that you
look at situations like these there's
been pretty massive incremental tax
placed on the public and when those
taxes happen that slows the business
velocity down it slows monetary velocity
and and it has this stagnation effect or
right it could just make things grind
slower which then works against you yep
just like if you have to pay your
college debt off you can't take risks in
your career like we're gonna have to pay
off this college debt known as the five
or ten trillion dollars we're gonna rack
up this madness I mean another bigger
question would be you know if we all
believe that this fully worked remote
like would you ever consider living in
some place that wasn't the u.s. a
different tax location right like 100
Michelle right and so suddenly that's a
new discussion that I would have never
thought I would been having well it's
really interesting because the last
couple of years it became so toxic and
hard to work in the valley we saw people
start leaving mm-hmm and in fact Peter
Pham lived up here for a long time and
let's write LA yeah and so some people
left for lifestyle but now I'm seeing
people go to Austin I mean people go to
the east side of Lake Tahoe the reno
side i'm seeing people go to Florida
Miami those seem to be the experts they
all have lower taxes yep more freedoms
and higher functioning government so
it's only a matter of time before
somebody says you know what you know
Vancouver and Toronto look pretty
interesting there are may
I'll be in the British Virgin Islands if
this is gonna work a lot of
entrepreneurial yeah and the weird ones
the weird ones the weird ones went
further there they their statement was I
talked to somebody in Puerto Rico this
morning entrepreneur big investor and
his statement was look you know I have a
US passport
and I pay you know four to five percent
total tax well yeah yom-yom crazy super
appealing and you know what being a
Malibu being in Puerto Rico it's kind of
the same thing right
it's like it's a beach yeah you know
education would be the hard thing to get
I know some people who move down there
and they were having a hard time
navigating education they may just have
to but if you're paying that little in
taxi just fly in a teacher that's the
question so there's just there's new
options right and and their options that
I didn't think I would see during my
lifetime to be totally honest but you
know that adjustment to work from home I
have a much heavier involvement now with
my kids education which actually really
like which has been really neat like I
said it hasn't slowed down my deal pace
I do feel I could be in different places
I suspect that from a capital
perspective like I still want to visit
my LPS and I think my LPS will still
like to see me in person but I don't
think it requires me to be with them all
the time right I think I can find ways
to keep that connectivity through
flights and just be a little bit lighter
you know on the forests in office
environment which we kind of previously
had